tonight senator Graham is building a
bipartisan coalition in the Senate to
call on China to shut down at so-called
wet markets which caused not just this
pandemic but our breeding grounds for
future ones he joins us now senator I
think that's just the beginning I think
the UK study showed 95% of this all
could have been prevented
yeah so the first thing I want to do is
get the United States Senate on the
record where we we don't blame Trump we
blame China the Chinese government is
responsible for 16,000 American deaths
and 17 million Americans being
unemployed is the Chinese government and
the way they behaved that led to this
pandemic this is the third one to come
out of China I want to make our response
to this so overwhelming that China will
change its behavior I want to get the
medical supply chain back in the United
States and I want to stop counseling
some debt that we owe to China because
they should be paying us not us paying
China so I think you're gonna see a
bipartisan pushback against China to
punish them so severely to deter them in
the future
what do you think of if we're gonna get
the country up and running and we're
gonna do it safely
we have great innovators in this country
Abbott came up with this five minute
test five minutes it's on size of a
toaster five now they can only produce
longer than I get on air show what's
that okay all right before you got on
the show well somehow we can get other
companies mass producing this to me
that's the key to do it safely and
securely I call the Germans I called the
German there's two kind of tests do you
have it or have you had it a lot of
people have had it don't know it we need
to test them get them back to work cuz
they're good to go and we need mass
tests to show that we don't have it
right now the road to economic recovery
is through testing labs we're turning
the corner on testing we're going to get
the economy back open safely and the way
to do it is have a testing regime that
allow people to go back to work safely
we've got better days lie ahead
all right senator thank you I think we
need those tests as many as possible
they've done a great service to the
country there's a lot of companies have
thank you